Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
uh, November 26, 2012. How are you doing?
Um, I hope you are fine. Okay.
I hope you are fine.
I hope during this holiday season that
you and yours and any pets you have from
mammals all the way down to gold fishes
are just doing great and thinking about
prostate cancer. Um,
all right. I'm actually,
I'm psyched to be back here in la.
I kind of have to keep my voice down
because the lovely Nia is still sleeping
upstairs. Um, I am basically,
I'm holding two microphones right now
because I've learned how to shut off the
external microphone on this thing and I
didn't have time to go back to guitars
and,
uh,
figure out how to just use one mic on
this and have it come into both my fucking
ears, you know, I don't know how to do it,
so I got to go down and talk to
one of those fucking guys. Sorry.
All right. I'm not good at this shit. So
I'm sitting here holding two microphones,
like kind of like John Bonham.
You know,
if I could compare myself to him
when he played the, the, the,
the track up four sticks, two sticks in
each in, right? I got two microphones.
He's got four sticks go a little
bottom this week. All right. Uh,
I've got a ton of shit to talk about
this week. A lot of sports stuff,
by the way. Um, just to get, you know,
just for, for all the people that
fucking hate when I talk sports,
this might be one you just
want to shut off. Okay.
We just fucking walk away and be like, oh,
why does he talk about middle earth? Um,
somebody informed me, by the
way, that Lord of the Rings, uh,
that middle earth thing,
it's not in the middle of the earth.
It's not like between our world
and the center of the earth.
Like I thought it was, they're
like, oh, hey shithead.
It's actually another fucking
plant. Well, what does it mean?
You know that that writers sucks so bad.
He couldn't come up with
another name for a planet.
They did that with fucking Superman's
parents, didn't they? Then he,
then he come from like the fucking
the planet of Zog or Zuora.
It was always big and Scifi. Like if
there was a planet or a guy's name,
it always had to started with a z cause
that just sounded like so fucking alien
cause nobody ever named a kid. Like
there was a couple of Xanax, you know,
what else is there other than Zach Zelda.
That's it for me. Zippy, you know.
Um, anyway, so let's, let's get into
the, uh, let's get into the sports here.
The soft fucking weird to
be holding two microphones.
I feel like one of those divas singers,
you ever see that back in the day when
they would have to be singing into one
microphone, then they'd have
another microphone taped
to the other one, you know?
Yeah, no, you did, you know, you did. You
had no, you did. What was that song? Yeah.
Not Jeeva three.
Bahbahbah remember that you used
to say live in Atlanta live?
No, sorry, I'm, that's
what I'm thinking of.
Axel rose with his
fucking white bike shorts.
You could actually wear white
fucking bike shorts, you know,
not under your pants.
Just that's what you could,
where he could have warned that with a
hat on backwards with the one size fits
all strap, making that red mark on his
forehead and know and just done a concert.
No one,
one had a fucking problem with it,
which I guess makes sense because
Friday market we're used to kind of walk
around like an adult diaper.
Did he do like shows like barefoot and
like tidy whities and he had like that
microphone like stand
that was sort cut off.
She was sort of like a majorette
and like singing a song.
Did that happen or did I just dream
that? Um, anyways, let's get to the, um,
let's get to the sports.
This week I think I,
I watch the most football Arik
possibly anybody in the United States.
It's on thanksgiving.
I went back to my hometown because
I was going back from my, uh,
my 25 year high school reunion.
G O g g h 25 fucking years.
Can you believe that?
I graduated high school 25 years ago
and I stayed back in the first grade.
So when I graduated I was 19 to do
the fucking math. I'm 44 years old.
I'm fucking, I they, they even
spotted me a year and I've still,
I'm still at my 25 year
high school fucking reunion.
And um, I got to admit I was
pretty nervous going in that thick,
you know what I mean?
I haven't seen a lot of those.
The kids that I went to school with,
a lot of them,
literally since the day we got our
diplomas and then that was fucking it.
So you know, you know the
deal, you want to walk in,
you want to see everybody looking good,
you want to see everybody happy and
everybody live in a life that they want to
be living. That was my biggest fear.
I didn't want to walk in there.
I didn't want to be reminded
of how fucking old I was
and I didn't want to see a
bunch of beaten down.
I like the 20 years.
And she walked out on me know that I
didn't want to see that, you know? And uh,
got it. Tell you, uh, um, my
fucking great held up great.
You know, everybody was looking good
man. Everybody looked down right?
Everybody looked like they were happy,
Eh, uh, it was a great fucking time.
So, uh, so there's one for your underrated
going to your high school reunion.
There's a lot of people have like,
uh, like hilarious react like,
like it's visceral.
Is that the right word?
Like if you mentioned that you go into
your reunion, you know what I mean?
People just,
you go on your high school reunion and
they just go off on this rant, dude,
I don't know.
Give a fuck if I never see another fucking
porch and I fucking hated everybody
at fucking, what the fuck? Fuck.
You know what I mean? And it's
just like, right. What happened?
Who stuffed you in a locker? You
know, who broke up with you? What?
What did you wish you did but you never
did? You know what I mean? You know,
first he was like that for,
as he was trying to fucking go on and
on and on and on and on about, dude,
I have no desire. I don't want to
fucking go. Like I was getting trashed.
I was at the, I was at
the stand, you know,
that little fucking a euro trash comedy
club that just opened up over there on
the east side on,
what is it on a third and 20th street,
you know, with that little Shishi food
and a can a little stage downstairs,
you know.
Um,
I was there and one of the guys fucking
one of the owners of the club fucking
hilarious. I told him I was going to my
high school union. I was excited because,
you know, I hadn't, I
hadn't seen these, you know,
I liked the kids I went to school with,
you know, I was excited to go and he goes,
you go to your high school reunion
and he starts laughing. He goes,
what do you need?
Closure.
That was probably the best
thing that anybody said.
I thought that that was fucking
hilarious. But, uh, yeah,
but I just kind of found like everybody
was just saying that, uh, they had no,
a lot of people going, I have no desire.
I don't know what happened. I was like,
those are the kids
who've got like bullied,
you know,
I dunno just fucking
what's his photos versus he ended up safe
versus he just tried to say he had no
desire to go to high school. He goes,
the go go to his high school reunion.
He goes, I hated high school. And
then I asked him, I said, all right,
well who fucking a beat you with your
own gym towel? What happened? He goes,
not do it. They never happen.
Never happen. You got just didn't,
I didn't like getting up in the
morning to have to go to it, you know,
like seven in the morning.
Quite possibly the dumbest reason
ever to not go to a high school. You,
it's like the fucking high school reunion
is going to be at night. You asshole.
You don't have to go
back to your home room.
Paul Versey and then I talked to him a
little bit more than I dragged it up some
chick fucking, I don't know
what, I don't know what happened.
Yeah,
dude, you couldn't fucking
pay me to fucking shut up.
Shut the fuck up though. The
people, I think you know something.
I bet Versie when he goes back,
he's going to fucking,
he's either gonna rent a flashy car or
he's just going to get himself in way
over his head on a car.
He actually owns,
you know,
why am I talking about this shit?
Anyway, so I went there and uh,
and just had a great fucking time.
Didn't drink because I didn't want to
be the fucking drunk guy, you know,
and God knows,
I really felt that my tolerance was
going to be way beyond most of my
classmates,
considering most of them are normal,
got married and had kids and
even if they want a booze,
they kinda got to wait til a,
you know, the coast is clear.
Whereas I can kind of still drink,
like I'm still in fucking,
not even like I'm in college, like,
like it's like it's spring break.
I can fucking drink like that whenever
I want it to. Which is not a good,
it's not a good thing for all belly
fat face here. So, um, I decided,
you know what,
I'll just start off with the cranberry
juice and a fucking lime and I'll endorse
somebody doing the, the fucking departed
joke. What do you get your period? Um,
and then I switched to water as an
I had a coke and that was just like,
you know what? I'm not going to
fucking drink. And uh, I had a, uh,
I had a great time. What the fuck was, I
just, I was leading towards something. Oh,
you know what? Everybody did and I
thought everything would be taken up.
Pictures of their kids.
I didn't see one picture of anybody's kid.
Everybody was just talking about shit.
All the dumb shit we used to do.
And uh,
and had a great time.
Just have really had a great time.
You know what a great story that I had
never heard. There was a buddy of mine,
he's the fucking gamble,
like big time,
used to bet on like baseball and he
had like his own landscaping company
whenever, like the baseball team
would win whatever team won a money,
he would then try and cut somebody's
backyard front yard in the same design as
the outfield of that team. And
it never looked like it. It just,
it looked like some sort
of fucked up design,
but he didn't know what he was doing
and he was high probably when he did it.
So somebody told me a
story about that kid.
He had bet the fucking Houston
Rockets way back in the day.
And a Houston had lost like two games
in a row. So we thought it was a gift.
You fucking buries the team. And they
ended up, uh, they just shit in a bed,
nobody's playing or whatever.
And he got so mad he picked up the
phone and he called long distance and he
said, uh, yeah,
and Houston last name Olijahwaun
and he wasn't doing it to make
the other person left. He,
he literally thought
that he was going to get,
I don't know if he was high or whatever,
he was trying to get this
guy's number to fucking bitch.
I'm out for losing and whatever,
50 bucks or 100 bucks in the game.
So it was basically just shit
like that. And, uh, all right,
now you guys getting sick of this. Okay.
Whatever. I had a great fucking time.
So if anybody who was at the high
school reunion is listening to me,
it was great seeing you and I'm glad
everything seems to be going great and
everybody's life. So anyway, so let's
get on with the sports here. Um,
here's one for you. First of all,
oh, I forgot to mention. Yeah,
I watched all these football.
I went to my Mike high
school rivalry game.
I went to that, we were two and seven.
The other team was like fucking a,
what are the eight and one and uh,
we actually beat them in overtime.
It was an away game, you
know, sent the other team,
fucking fans home with their heads
hanging on Turkey day made me feel fucking
great. And then I watched, uh, I watched
the first game was that the lions,
Texas.
Then I watch the next game,
cowboys and then I watched the Patriots.
Uh,
I gave him was fucking unbelievable.
And don't worry Jeff Fans,
I'm not going to fight. I
get it. If you've noticed,
I really haven't trashed you guys to share
despite the fact I really could have.
I just haven't.
The only reason why I ever really fucking
trashed you guys was because Rex Ryan
talked all that shit.
You know,
he hasn't talked shit in two years
and I laid off you. Okay. So, um,
anyways, you know that guy
always make fun of the fireman.
I always say it gets on his boyfriend
shoulders like you some hot chick at a Bon
Jovi concert,
a fireman,
ed fucking retired if you
haven't heard about this.
Okay.
He couldn't fucking take it anymore.
Why?
Because the Patriots beat the
team so bad. No, cause he,
he has to enter another
fucking jets rebuilding. No,
cause he got sick of the Conti fucking
jet fans getting in his fucking grill
cause he's wearing a Sanchez Jersey.
The same fucking people who
are going calling Mark Sanchez,
Sanchez, Sanchez. A few
fucking years later,
they jump off the fucking bandwagon.
Now they get into the face of this old
fucking retired a fireman on Thanksgiving
getting in his face and
he finally just decided,
what the fuck am I doing the fuck
am I doing? Fuck these people.
And you know what I say? I
say, good for you firemen. Ed,
don't take no shit off nobody.
Here's the article. New York
jets, super fan firemen, ed,
who for decades has fueled home crowds
with his famous j e t s cheer has decided
to r e t I r e retire.
Um,
I don't name names,
I won't say his last name.
Who created a stir Thanksgiving night
when he left metlife stadium at halftime
of the jets. 49 to 19 loss. Yeah.
Along with half the fucking crowd.
And then he deleted his Twitter account.
He announced on Sunday night that
he will no longer attend home games.
Is Firemen Ed good for you?
Good for you.
Okay.
You gotta go down there and dress up
like a fucking clown to get these people
going.
Only to have these people getting your
grill in the fucking bathroom screaming
at you.
Shame on you jets fans.
And I know what you jet fans are going
to say. It was a select few people. No,
it wasn't. It was, it was probably
almost all of you. And you know why?
Because you're horrific human beings
and that's why God only let you win one.
Um,
anyways,
he says the stadium has become divided
because of the quarterback controversy.
He claims the fact that I chose to wear
a Mark Sanchez Jersey this year and that
fans think I'm on the payroll,
which is an outright lie,
have made these confrontations more
frequent, whether it's in the stands,
the bathroom or the parking lot.
These confrontations are
happening on a consistent basis.
Wow. So he just said fuck
it. And then Rex Ryan, Oh,
uh, I, I actually hung around and watched
his press conference where he just kept
saying the same. You, oh,
we're going to throw it all.
We're going to come out next week.
I'm going to play hard.
I mean that's all we know
how to do. You know, it just,
you know that that same fucking shit.
You know
the same guy that one year
when they lifted the salary
cap and the jets went out
and fucking one bought everybody,
he's like, well, kicked off
shit out of any fucking to move league.
It's just great watching him
eat a big slice of humble pie.
And the final question of
the press conferences, rex,
do you think you'll still be here
next year? And he just goes, yes I do.
Yes I do.
Any more questions?
And there was nothing and he had to
walk off on that one and I thoroughly
enjoyed it, thoroughly fucking
enjoyed it. So there you go.
But this guy says he's going to
keep going to the, to the games.
He's just not going to the
game. You know, as firemen, ed,
the guys wearing the Sanchez
Jersey according to him as
like he's being loyal to
this guy really is a fan. You
know something to people go, dude,
the guy used to be a fucking dolphins
fan, you know? All right, that works.
If he jumped on the bandwagon,
it became a patriots fan when the
Patriots got good or if he jumped on the
bandwagon, you know, uh,
with the giants or the Steelers or
any other team that was good dude.
He went from the dolphins to the
jets. Okay. No end. He did it in 75.
That was a major step backwards. All
right. According to what I've read. Okay.
And 75, the fuck had dolphins. They, it,
they'd want to two Superbowls back to
back. Superbowls had a perfect season,
went to three Superbowls in a row.
All in the early seventies.
They still had Bob Greasy,
I think Larry,
his uncle was already in the WFL and
maybe came back with the giants at that
point. Fucking rain man. Here,
this is all from my football cards that
I looked at a zillion times when I was a
kid rather than studying in high school.
And um,
okay,
who the fuck did, did they even
have Richard Todd at that point?
Joe Nemeth was gone. Yeah, I
think they just got Richard Todd.
That was it.
Yeah.
So this guy, this guy paid his fucking
dues. He went to a zillion games.
He's the only guy still the
balls to where? Sanchez Jersey.
This guy was actually a fan and he
got trashed by other fucking France.
I find that really fucking interesting.
MMM.
Yeah. Had it really actually taps into
this. This question, I got this this week.
Somebody said, Bill, do you give a
shit? He said, hey bill, love you work,
but you give a shit about your fans
doesn't look like it and sad to see.
I don't even, what the fuck? What does
that mean? Doesn't look like it does.
Is My website subpar?
I know the audio was bad last week,
Bill. Well, you know you get, sorry.
You're going to have to elaborate a
little bit more. What happened? Did you,
how did Jay, you keep sending
emails and I haven't read one yet.
Did you have a cold last week
and asked me to send you a fucking card
and I did what? What does that mean?
Do I give a shit about my fence?
First of all?
I don't know. All right.
This is what I feel like.
I feel you have a fucking responsibility
to give somebody a God damn show.
That's what you have.
Go out there,
give somebody their fucking
bodies worth all right.
And I like to think I do that.
So where the fuck is that and what more?
What more do I got to do for you?
Where the t shirt or your company,
you know,
you think that's sad? You know,
I think just fucking shad.
I think that fucking emails said,
what are you doing?
You know what? What the, I don't even
know where the fuck that comes from.
Do I give a shit about
if it has? No, I don't.
I want to go back to standing in a a
fucking function room in a hotel room in
front of 80 people who didn't even
know there was going to be comedy.
Give me a fucking break. Okay. I don't, I
don't know what your, your level of, uh,
I have to give shit. Let me ask
you, let me ask you a question, sir.
Do you give a shit about the p the,
the, the people that you're fans of?
You know,
cause I, I gotta be honest with
you. I don't, I thought I did,
but I fucking love ACDC.
Absolutely fucking love them.
And I had another bad example cause
they've never really fell off.
They've always sold a bunch of albums.
I loved a lot of bands in the
80s loved them. All right.
But when they fell off in the fucking
nineties I didn't keep going to their
shows. I didn't send them
cards going, hey man,
hang in there.
I didn't,
I totally fucking slipped
and made fun of them.
I make fun of hair metal.
To this day,
I guess they make fun of myself to saying
I can't believe some of the fucking
shows I went to.
But you know what I mean?
It's those people who are still fucking
going to those shows what their hairs
teased up,
acid washed jeans,
this fireman Ed sitting there was still
wearing the Sanchez, Sanchez gene,
a fucking jersey.
I guess that that is a true fanatic.
But the rest of us I think are a,
you know,
we're fucking hot and cold isn't the
real relationship most fans have with the
musician and actor,
a fucking whatever.
MMM.
An athlete don't, aren't you really kind
of just a fan? As long as they're good,
you know,
they sold a lot of Sanchez jerseys.
Okay.
And everybody loved him until
he didn't start playing well,
and now everybody fucking hates him.
You know,
I think that's, that's more,
that's the reality, you know,
so you don't sound, well, I don't know.
I don't know where that's coming from,
so I can't really judge you. But, uh,
I do give a shit about the
people who come to my shows, uh,
unless they have some sense of
entitlement where they feel like,
you know,
I bought a ticket to your show and
despite the fact that you then did a show,
so I already got my money's worth,
that I definitely deserve more shit.
You know,
they don't consider the bonus round,
you know, taking pictures and
signing whatever the fuck they want.
They don't consider that like, oh,
hey, this guy's actually this guy.
Technically it doesn't even have to
fucking be out here. And He came out here.
Most people appreciate that. Oh glad
you came out, you know. Ah Yeah, no,
thank you for coming out. Right. That
fucking little tit for tat thing.
Those people who fucking sit there and
they come up hammered and nudge it and
they have like a,
you know,
sign 500 fucking things and I want to
have a 20 minute conversation with you
despite the fact there's another
40 people waiting behind you.
Who else would have jobs and shit to
do? And when I say I'll come, sorry,
this other people. And then you flip out
and say that I'm some Prima Donna cont.
Yeah. I don't give a shit
about them. I hope I answered
your question, sir. You're,
you're, I, I,
you have me wondering what I had and
he need to go redo my fucking website.
Maybe update some more fucking photos.
You know, look, there's people out there,
this disc comedians out there who are
funny and a really good at recording
themselves and have really interactive
websites if that's what you're looking
for. I hate to say you stopped
at the wrong kiosk because, uh,
I'm Kinda not that guy. All
right? Okay. There we go.
All right. Hey, you know what,
why don't, why don't we, uh,
why don't we drop out of that? We'll
do a little bit of a all things comedy,
everybody.
Would you like to know what's going
on on the all things comedy network,
the podcasting network that
I was started by myself,
Al Madrigal and a couple
other peoples there, um,
that will eventually take
over the podcasting world. Um,
here's some updates. Thompson
Gara. Absolutely fucking hilarious.
I'm telling you, this guy is going
to be one of the guys. All right.
He's doing an hour long
comedy special December 4th,
if flappers comedy club and Burbank,
a great old school comedy club in Burbank.
Plenty of parking.
A not a bad seat in the house. He
wants the club packed. Please. Um,
let's see. It says, please extend an
offer to be placed on Tom's guests.
Let's tell your audience to email Tom
at Tom Segura at [inaudible] dot com.
It's t o m capital s e g u r a@me.com.
Um, and then how many tickets they want
and be sure to write December 4th in the
subject line.
So I guess these are free tickets.
You guys want to go to a free show?
Great.
Up and coming comic here telling you I'm
going to be one of the guys free show.
Flappers comedy club. December
4th email. Tom segura@me.com.
How many tickets you want with December
4th in the subject line? All right,
a couple other ones. Um, Randy
from the bone zone, the bone zone,
I, new podcasts added to all
things comedy. On a recent episode,
he had the creator of the cartoon
network show adventure time,
Penn Ward as a guest if
you'd like to listen to that.
And Are Greg Baron of the walking room,
uh, his band, the reigning monarchs,
uh, or start an Indiegogo campaign
to make a record tomorrow.
It would be going on for the next 45 days.
We could plug, that would be awesome.
If not, I'll hang myself. Okay.
That was the part he wrote it
anyways. Got All things comedy,
Baron's fucking hilarious. Uh,
and check that shit out. Okay.
And that is it. All right,
now back to the fucking spa.
Wait,
I gotta I gotta read a little
fucking advertising here. I've got,
I've got a grease. The grease the
palms here. What do we got here?
What do we got here? Oh,
stamps.com everybody, um, egg.
You want to stop going to the post office
and you would you just like be able to
do everything you can do
with a post office at home?
Just go to stamps.com you can avoid
all the hassle man of going to the post
office during the busy holiday season.
Oh yeah. This is even more of a bonus.
You don't want to be going down there
cause you know you're going to shop late
and then you got to ship all your crap
back to these people you don't even care
about. Okay. Would it to be nice to
not have to stand in line to do that?
Everything you want to
do with the post office,
you can do right from your desk or
at home sitting in your pajamas.
You can buy and print official US postage
using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or package
the instant you need it, then mail,
then the mail man picks it up.
So easy and convenient.
I use stamps.com to send all of my DVDs
to any of the road gigs that I have.
You should do it too.
Right now you got a special offer
when you use my name for a, B u. R. R.
A No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer
includes a digital scale and up to $55 in
free postage. So given you 55 bucks
during the holiday season, so don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click at the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in [inaudible],
B u r. R. That's stamps.com enter Berbee
you are are okay. Back to the podcast.
So,
um,
all right. He's a big as another fucking
thing. I got a bone I have to pick.
And you know some, I really came
down hard on the jets. I have fans.
I know a lot of your fans didn't leave.
You guys are the real fucking fans
and towards the end of that game,
if you looked around, if you really
want to see the real fans, yeah,
if you were still fucking there
and not wearing a patriots jersey.
I always hate people who fucking leave
early when your team's taken an ass
kicking from the other team,
cause the end of the other team's fans
get to like air quote takeover your, your,
your stadium. She never
let that happen. Okay.
You should have them walking out with
their heads down nervous that they're
going to get beat down by 60,000 fucking
fans. That's what, that's what I feel. Um,
all right. Okay. As always. Okay.
We fucked with the east coast.
Now how about the west coast? Did you
guys see a Koby Bryant the other night?
I forget who the fuck they were playing.
They lost another game.
Things aren't going well out there.
So there's 10 seconds left in the game.
You know,
there's no way the Lakers can come
back to down like by eight or nine or
something like that.
So the other team has the ball,
they get an inbound it there at half
court and they're just standing there
dribbling it out. Right? And
you just stand there, you wait.
Then the horn blows and then
everybody just goes and shake hands.
And you're going to the
locker room. Well Colby, yeah,
we'd score 30 points that night.
Never dental.
He thought he was God's gift to fucking
everything. He just walks off the court,
left his teammates there.
Right?
One of the most diva fucking
things I've ever seen in my life,
just fucking walks off court with
the whole, Hey, I scored 30 points.
I don't know what's wrong with the rest
of you. Totally setting himself apart.
Just an absolute fucking cancer.
Right?
So I'm watching ESPN go nay. Let's
see what they're going to do. Is He,
they finally gonna fucking
criticize this guy, Steven,
a Smith who I love,
who will rip somebody a new
asshole whenever it is deserved.
He goes on and he goes and
they'd go, Steven A. Smith,
what do you think about that?
How he just walked off?
You see Dwight Howard looking at him like,
are you serious?
What do you think about that? And
Steven A. Smith was just like,
well Kobe Bryant has a
very high basketball Iq,
which I don't even know
what that fucking means.
He has a very high basketball
Iq. So what does that mean? He,
but he can't use a fork.
You know
when the guy has been the best
guy in the league for like what,
10 12 fucking years.
But whatever.
He has a very high basketball Iq and this
is just evident evidence of the level
of frustration the man is feeling about
the current state of the situation.
I mean,
Paul was Saul,
he could not hit a shot and he starts
ripping all the other fucking Lakers.
Just,
that's the type of Shit I can't fucking
stand just sitting there kissing the ass
of a fucking star. Colby Bryant
is a fucking cancer. The guys,
he ran shack out of town, you know,
they want three fucking titles.
And he still wasn't happy.
He called Rocco.
Remember that shack gone.
Goes to Miami one a title.
There's another one the Lakers could
have got that year. You know not,
I don't want to win.
I'd rather have it all be me.
It's all about me, right?
He should've been benched,
benched for the first quarter.
The next game,
and this is the same guy that they
talk about in the same breath,
is Michael Jordan, the Magic
Johnson's, the Larry Bird's.
Let me tell you something. Those
guys never would have done that shit.
Fucking ridiculous. Fucking
ridiculous. That guy.
Can you imagine that? Nag, Nag.
Now you got to go walk in the locker
room after Colby just left, left you out.
They're like, yeah, you guys
all suck. Go fuck yourselves.
And then you've got to walk into
the locker room and you what?
You can't say anything to him.
Okay?
You know what they should have?
They should have fucking gone in there.
And all of them just hung him by his
fucking shorts. Give him a big Wedgie.
How high would that Hook have to be?
I mean, what is he fucking six eight.
I mean what? Gimme a fucking,
you just walk out and it Steven.
A Smith doesn't say anything about it.
He just starts talking about how smart
he is at the game of basketball and how
he's really frustrated like the
other Lakers aren't frustrated.
Let me ask you this, like
a fence. How many fucking,
this is a great thing about lake
affairs to these fucking morons.
The very next game will
be chanting MVP at the,
a guy who's run coaches out of town,
ran shack out of town.
Fuck the team out of another
fucking championship. Most likely
it's check in his prime.
That's another thing too.
This fucking guy has had
the Lakers organization.
He hasn't by the short hairs
hasn't by the fucking balls.
He does whatever he wants to do.
It's embarrassing.
Then Tony should have sat him.
He should have walked right in
the locker room just like Colby.
What the fuck was that?
You know this is a team.
You're not playing the first
quarter. Tomorrow night.
Hey, I don't want to hear it.
Shut your face, but once in your fucking
life. Black to say it in Italian too.
You know what,
he'd be a better player because of it.
They should have a team meeting
and address his continuous,
you know, and you know, he get all
emotional, you know when he does,
when he puckers up his lips,
you know, like we did one a,
when they got beat by the Pistons or he
got beaten up in the conference finals
or that skank out and fucking nod.
Denver said the sheer they said about him,
he had that, he did that thing
with his lips. That's what
he would do. Yeah. Colby,
you kind of a cunt and he'd
start making that face.
Okay,
look, the guy's a beast. He wants to
win. I totally respect that. You know,
you don't do that to your fucking
teammates and, and Steven A. Smith.
You know what shame on you. You
have a very high broadcaster, Iq.
You know what the fuck he did and you
know why you didn't hold his feet to the
fire. Then he'd go at fucking power. Saul,
you go up to the guy who looks
like a giant Kenny Loggins come on.
I Dunno. I don't like that.
I'm like that star as kicks it.
Cause you know what happens
is if you shit on him,
then you can't get the interviews
anymore. You know what I mean? Well,
maybe he played some sort of pickup game
at your son's eight year old birthday
party and you don't want to jeopardize
that for the nine year old birthday.
Just something going on there where I
was just, I couldn't fucking believe it.
The fucking guy walks off the
court with 10 seconds left.
Fuck all you guys. This wasn't my fault.
It's your fault. What else could it mean?
You guys take the fucking loss?
You
take this embarrassing gloss.
I'm above this
and Steven Aca, he has a very
high basketball. Oh my God.
Disgusting. Um, that was,
it was borderline offensive.
I never get offended. Um, all
right, here we go. Pillow Bill.
My name is Stephanie Mallow.
Molossia.
Okay. Why did I just read your fucking
name? Well, you know what you said it, uh,
my, my fiance, my fiance and I are fans.
We saw him in New York and new haven.
I'm looking to find more information
regarding booking bill for my wedding,
uh,
in 2014.
All right.
Now this email was sent to me because
they thought that I would think,
but this Gig was funny and was beneath
me. But a 2014 is a long ways off. So,
uh,
who knows what could happen.
Okay.
No, ma'am. You know, something, there's no
way I would ever work a wedding because,
uh, just out of respect
for your grandmother and
everybody else who's got to be
there and, uh, you know what I mean? But
I'm, I'm, I'm definitely not above it.
Long time ago, I got it. I
got to trash and from, uh,
the late great Patrice O'Neal,
Kevin Hart, Rich Vos, Jim Norton,
murderer's row, Keith Robinson,
everybody trashed me because,
uh,
I was, I was basically debating whether
or not I was going to do this gig. It was,
the Gig was basically, I think I've told
this before, but just for new listeners,
I'll, I'll go through it real quick. Uh,
the Yankees were playing the Atlanta
Braves in the fucking world series.
I'd never been to a world
series game. And, uh,
so they called up the comedy cellar
and they wanted to Comedians,
um, they wanted to, comedians to do, to
do this fucking Gig,
which was basically they'd rented two
buses and they were going to drive up to
the stadium and they wanted a
comedian to do stand up on the bus.
And a, they offered it to me and Jim
Norton and me and Jim sat there going,
are you going to do it? I'm like, I
dunno. I know you're going to do it.
I don't know it's going to be raffled
both wanting to go to the game. So on,
but announced to me,
he told us that he wasn't going to
fucking do it and I was still hemming and
hawing about it and I made
fun of his shirt and he said,
whatever busboy and the whole
fucking table stopped and
everybody was like, what?
And he goes,
Bill Burns doing a fucking Gig on
a bus to get a world series ticket.
And there just wasn't enough time
for me. Try to explain. Well,
I'm just contemplating it. They
offered it to him too. It was over.
And I took a fucking, like about a 50
minute pounding, 50 minutes straight,
like a headlining set of
just getting trashed. And um,
so anyway, so they sent this fucking,
and you know what? I actually,
I didn't end up doing the Gig,
but still I don't,
I don't think the Gig was that bad.
A gig that would have been
such easy fucking Gig.
You just get on the bus and
you just trashed the Yankees
and when you run out of
Shit, you make fun of somebody on,
hey look and look at the tits on her.
That's all you'd have to dope.
You make fun of yourself.
This has got to be the girl.
You know,
a lot of you are probably
thinking this is a horrible,
this is one of the greatest gains.
Just make fun of that.
This is actually a good gig in your
career. You could be drinking with them,
having a chance,
fucked a Yag fuck the Gado.
Just get them genuinely yell at other
people on the site. You can just,
anything to distract you.
Just filibuster for fucking 20 minute
ride up there and you go to world series
game for free. I stand
by it. I stand by it.
I still don't think it was a bad gig,
although the person who did the Gig,
but he was less experienced than me
who actually maybe I'll have him on the
podcast someday.
He actually has his own TV show right now.
See that and I don't,
so there was magic on that bus. He
actually did it and I finally, I told him,
I took the pounding and uh,
you know,
took it like a champ.
Just sat there and took it fucking killed.
Killed me for 50 fucking minutes and
I never gave up his name. I was like,
that guy in casino getting is.
I popped out.
I didn't even bring it up that I actually,
I could have just said,
I'm not doing the Gig.
I gave it to somebody else.
Well maybe I hadn't given it to him
at that point had I, I can't remember.
I just remember the end. I was still
gonna do it until it finally it died down.
And Patrice just said to me, Bill, he
goes, I will stand in front of that bus.
You can't do that Gig. All right. You want
to go to the world series, buy a ticket.
And I was just like,
wow,
I guess I should have some sort of
fucking self esteem smash cut to four
fucking eight years later,
10 whatever.
How many years it isn't being
offered a wedding gig. Um,
yeah, I'm going to say no,
I'm just, because even
even if, uh, you know,
I needed to fill the calendar, it's just
like, it's your wedding day. You want it,
you want it to be nice. You
don't want somebody going,
I mean, you just saw my act.
You saw what I talked about.
I'm talking about the fucking apocalypse
and people eating puppies. I mean, you,
you really want me to,
I don't have like a wedding set.
If that's what you're asking me,
I really wouldn't know. Uh, I
really wouldn't know what to do. So,
uh, but I'm, I'm great. I'm glad
that you had a good time. Uh,
that new haven Gig was the shit. And
that's something I definitely want to do.
Again, like I said, I want to come
back for the Harvard Yale game,
go to a home game there and I just
want to listen in to some of the
conversations and who knows. I'll
probably be sitting next to a, one of the,
a future president or maybe someone who's
in the future will be the guy who has
the on Hai like cloaked road
before he stabs at Virgin.
It's some sort of Bilderberg
cookout. Um, alright, apocalypse.
Hello billion. I am dedicated podcast
listener. I'm a big fan of, I do.
I've noticed your recent
musings on preparing for the
apocalypse, buying guns. He,
I haven't done any of it.
I just think about doing it and the Nia
just looks at me and just shakes her
head like you're out of your
fucking mind. Uh, buying guns,
learning how to hunt and survive when
the inevitable human population bubble
bursts and we run out of food and water.
Uh,
well I don't think that's
going to happen anytime soon.
It eventually will happen and it may very
well happen within my lifetime. Okay.
Okay.
Well I guess you plan on living a long
time then sir. Um, cause you're like,
I don't think is going to
happen to it at anytime soon,
but probably in my lifetime.
When you think that, you know,
when the overall history of how long
man has walked the planet and woman,
that that's kind of soon we've been
around how long we've been around.
Okay.
A hundred thousand years. I don't
fucking know. We'll leave it at,
we have been around that long.
Have we?
Jesus was walking the
earth 2000 years ago.
Okay.
He didn't have an iPad or the fuck he did.
They went to kill him.
Did they,
did they use a lethal
injection or electric chair?
They tied them to a fucking stake
if you believe in that stuff, you
know, I'm not trying to offend anybody.
Some people don't
believe it even happened,
so people only believe
that the guy even existed.
Some people think it was just all made up.
I'm not trying to offend anybody,
you know?
Yeah.
Anyways, like you, I grew up in a big
city with the, with middleclass parents,
relatively sheltered and didn't learn
a lot of the basic survival skills as a
kid, as an adult with children.
I think it's vital capitals,
vital that they learn basic fundamental
skills of survival, building a fire,
making shelter, hunting, et cetera.
I picked up hunting as an adult
and I have to say it has changed my
understanding of the nature of the natural
world man's role as a Predator on the
planet. How we evolve, where
we fit in, et cetera. Um,
I cannot underscore the appreciation.
You will have a who actually get
out there and harvest your own food.
Do you have to use the word harvest
when you killing a living thing?
That's really creepy to me.
Just say,
fucking blow the brains
out of a fucking elk. Um,
prepare it and then feed yourself and
your loved ones. It's an experience.
Someone who sees the world as you
do, we'll surely appreciate. Yeah,
I think that's awesome.
But what am I going to do?
Am I gonna I'm gonna go shoot a fucking
deer and then tie it to the front of my
Prius and drive back down to la.
Do you understand what will happen to me?
I'll fucking liberal it is out here.
Yeah.
I'll get fucking stabbed to death with
horse shoes on Hollywood boulevard.
Um,
if you want to get really back to basics,
you should learn to hunt without a gun.
I actually think that's cool.
Hunting without a gun is great.
You said bullets make life easy. I,
I keep the bullets for a, for people.
Um, you said bullets make life easy,
but when the shit really hits the fan,
you're going to need to save those bullets
in all likelihood of protect yourself
from, yeah, it's from other
people actually already read that.
So maybe his idea was already in
my head. Uh, don't kid yourself.
The most dangerous animal on the planet
is a hungry human who wants what you
have. Forget about lions, bears, et
Cetera. They don't compare. Yeah,
that's God damn right.
I don't live next to a lion,
but I lived next to a
bunch of human beings. Um,
learn to hunt with a bow and arrow.
The arrows are recoverable and reusable.
If you want to get really fancy,
you have someone take you out to hunt
with dogs or birds of prey or both?
Dude, I got to say, birds of prey freaked
me out. They really freaked me out.
They just a, they don't look,
they're not domesticated.
I don't like how you to
put like that fucking uh,
special needs helmet over their
fucking heads or else they'll,
I don't know what they'll do now.
Like those talents.
It's like they got a butterfly
knife attached to both foot.
They like Freddy Krueger and just one day,
I don't know what's going to happen.
You know, they confuse my face with some
sort of red chested Robin or something.
I don't know. Clot my eyes. Um,
and they always look angry.
Like Apple's always looked pissed off,
you know, it's got that Dan did offline
right above his nose, his beak. I mean,
by the way, just in case you think
I'm a fringe Wacko, a Wackadoo.
I am a board certified physician and my
wife went to both medical school and law
school. Well, that really did
improve anything, sir. You
just said that by the way,
if you think, and if you think I'm crazy.
Uh, I also flew the space shuttle, sir.
Um, well tell me how do I do,
where do I learn how to hunt?
Okay.
I want to, you know what I want
to kill? I want to kill a varmint.
I could kill a varmint.
Um,
could I though? I'd have to be
really hungry. I know. I could do it.
Anybody could do it.
You just have to be hungry enough.
Okay.
Unless she knew about berries,
you know.
Oh, wouldn't it be the worst you
fucking out in the wilderness, right?
And you don't know how
to survive our hunt,
but you're with somebody out there
who knows how to survive and is like a
fucking Vegan and you're just sitting
there eating nuts and berries and shit.
Right.
Stick in your face in a beehive,
trying to look up some honey getting stung
in the face like a goddamn brown bear
instead of just killing a rabbit.
Okay?
And you guys got to deal with this guy.
You know what happened? Eventually,
eventually you just,
you just,
you pick up a branch per tenant was like
a walking stick and you just the club
over the head just in a
moment of frustration and
then have that panic of being
alone in the wilderness,
not knowing how to get out.
Yeah.
Did I just pitch a short film?
Um,
you know,
I smoked a cigar last night and I got
like third of the way through it and I was
like, I'm done with this fucking
habit. Now I got a stupid fucking,
what do you call those things? Human
door. Anybody want to fucking humidor?
You just want one.
You want to just take this fucking
disgusting habit out of my life.
I don't want to do it anymore.
You know,
it's fucking horrific to
horrific fucking habit.
You know how I know it is because
there's not a bad smell to a dog.
Dog will walk up to another up dogs fresh
pile of shit and stick his nose right
in it and can have it there. It
doesn't gag or anything. All right.
If I'm sitting there with my cigar
and won't come anywhere near me.
Now what does that tell you? Said
gars smell worse than poodle. Shit.
Okay. All right. The truth behind
pink a bill, you should check out the,
the outer documentary
titled Pink Ribbons Ink.
It discusses the culture and popularity
of breast cancer awareness month while
exposing some of the hypocrisy
involved in case you don't watch it.
Let me give you a couple of highlights.
You can talk about the film
without actually having seen
it. Well, thank you sir.
You got right down to the core of
who I am. Give me the cliff notes.
What do we got here?
Why do we got here? Um,
the woman that invented the pink
rhythm as a method to raise awareness
quickly. One of the most annoying
phrases out there raising awareness.
Could it be any more fucking vague,
vague. Cheevan I am aware it's breast
cancer awareness month. I got it.
Everyone's in the NFL is wearing pink.
I am aware job done now nobody can fuck
with all the money that you took in.
Is that the loophole?
That's what I'm trying to guess.
Then you go out and you and you,
you buy a,
a pink Bentley but they can't
get you cause it's pink, right.
I'm raising awareness.
Okay.
And I spent this amount of money
on this car to show how theory,
if the problem is, um, raise
awareness with breast cancer at a,
was approached by self, sorry,
the woman that invented the, uh,
the, the, the shit was, uh,
approached by the magazine,
self magazine aimed at
the ladies and s the SD.
Estee Lauder, Estee Lauder,
Esther. How do you say that?
Estee.
Estee Lauder.
That's one of those things I've heard
people say it's lean times. So it just,
I don't know, in the early nineties, uh,
to partner with these corporations
knowing that these greedy costs were only
interested in the pink room as a
way to increase their bottom line.
The creator of the original
pink ribbon refuse to correct,
collaborate and told self and
Estee Lauder, Estee Lauder, uh,
to go fuck themselves.
So these corporate fucks created a pink
ribbon that was technically a different
color and the pink saturation began.
Another interesting point the
film makes is that companies like,
why did you have to pick Estee Lauder?
I just set it right. Estee Lauder.
There it is. Promote breast
cancer awareness by turning pink.
The labels of products that contain
carcinogens isn't that fucking hilarious.
Uh, of the money that buying
all this pink shit raises,
apparently only 15% of it is used for
researching prevention of breast cancer.
Most of the research goes to figuring
out which cancer drugs work best for
treating the disease once it occurs.
Yeah.
And nothing preventative because
the money is not in the cure.
It's in the treatment.
Anyway,
check out the movie pink Ribbon Inc
it's available on Netflix instant.
Thanks for the podcast and all the
free funny. Well you're welcome
sir. Um, yeah, yeah. I mean,
I'm at that read that
book that I'm reading. Uh,
I may take it for whatever you want. I
mean, obviously I'm not a nutritionist,
but the,
uh,
that eat to live book where it talks about
vegetables and that type of thing and
uh, and fruits and all the,
uh, antioxidants and how it,
I know it helps regenerate some damaged
cells from all the shit that you do.
Yeah.
I really believe it just once a day,
if you just have a giant fucking salad
and eat a couple pieces of fruit,
you can offset all that other stuff
because I got to tell you there's no way
I'm ever going to a 100%, uh, just never
have a steak again. You know what I mean?
Sorry. It's just some steer out there
that's going to have to fucking die.
By the way.
Why do they have that in the commercial?
Why do they have a cow saying,
eat more chicken?
They don't feed your cows.
It steers and a steer is basically a bowl
with its ball's locked off as far as I
can tell.
That's what I was told back in the day
when I would do college gigs and a,
I would see both randomly see a ball and
I would see a bunch of cows and then I
would see stare and I'd be like, all
right, a bulls, a male, a cow's a female,
what the fuck is a steer?
And they've said it was a bowl
with the balls lopped off.
So I'm one of the like Unix. They don't
hit puberty. I don't fucking know.
But anyways. Um, next
question here on the podcast,
a Gyno gain. Oh, hey bill,
what's your opinion on this?
My wife recently had a Gyno
appointment. I hate that.
Just gynecologist gain or makes it
sound like it's all goopy and gross.
It's disgusting.
But that's what I think.
A gynecological appointment
as a thoughtful husband,
I remembered. So later in the day
I casually asked my wife, hey,
how'd the appointment go? She said, the
doctor said, everything looks great.
I was incredulous.
I don't know what that means,
but I think it means you're
upset. He said, I said, what?
What did he say? She said,
he said, everything looks great.
I said, no, no, no, no, no,
no. Wait, wait, wait. Really?
Really? What? What? What were his,
his, his exact words? She said,
those were his exact words. Everything
looks great. Then he writes,
motherfucker, are you kidding me, Bill?
Does that comment seemed completely
unprofessional. You, I mean,
he's a freaking doctor.
He should have said something like,
everything looks in order or everything
looks healthy. These God damn doctors.
Remember that doctor man. See any
from Melrose place. He was a real sob.
They're all like that.
Especially these creepy guy knows
what kind of becomes a Gyno.
Stop saying that word,
sir. The fuck is this?
What the fuck?
Just popped up on my goddamn computer
in the middle of a critical moment.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Um, anyways, get back to,
plus my wife is very attractive and now
he's telling her that her pussy looks
great.
The guy says,
Hey, I know a pussy looks great.
That's part of why I married her.
We're really fucking frost me though,
is that I had to pay this guy 50
a $50 copay for his observation.
It's like he's laughing at me anyway.
What do you think about all that?
And I wouldn't mind knee
is a opinion as well. Uh,
should I get involved here?
Yeah.
Thanks. Don't mention my name.
All right. All right. Um,
okay.
You know what you,
what you should do is just do what you
just did to me because what you say it is
funny.
Did you just say it to your wife in a
funny way and just be, and just be like,
what? Who, what does this guy look like?
Does he look like this doctor
[inaudible] from Melrose place?
I don't know what he looks like, but
that guy sounds like a fucking sleazebag,
you know?
Yeah.
Why does he get to just look at
you? You know, I had to buy a ring.
I had a wine and dine United
to do all this type of stuff.
I actually love you and I only
see it a couple of times a month.
You'll get on there
for not just something,
there's gotta be something funny though,
because there is something actually, uh,
um, I don't know, women
might not agree with this,
but there's something caring about this,
you know,
I see how much, you know,
you're into your wife,
you don't like some other guy just looking
at it without saying something. Ah,
you know, ah, shit, my
fucking phone. Who is this?
Who is this and what do you want them
in the middle of talking about Gyno? Um,
yeah, I think, you know, if
your wife's a hot shit, she'll,
she'll get a kick out of it. Like that's
the kind of thing that would make a,
yeah,
that would make me laugh if I ever
said something like that. Oh yeah.
How long was he checking you out?
Did he have you lay on your belly?
Okay.
Yeah, I gotta check the other side
of the, uh, the, uh, your vagina,
just a on your belt is lay on your belly
and sort of, uh, just point your, your,
your buttocks. They've used like those,
those words, so it didn't sound perverted,
you know, at the ceiling. Um,
oh, speaking of perverted,
I can't even get into this.
Yeah.
Let's just say early on the podcast I
mentioned that I went to something and saw
some people that hadn't
seen in a long time and uh,
let's just say,
uh,
some older creep from the faculty
showed up for whatever fucking reason.
You know,
there's always one.
There's one,
um, creepy. Okay.
Overrated, underrated, um,
underrated. Ah, going to your
high school reunion, Eh, uh,
overrated. Getting fucking blitzed
at your high school. If you,
I think if you'd like, you have
your five year, your 10 year,
you can go in there and get a little bit.
Fuck, you definitely get drunk at your,
your five year, 25 year. You know, you
get a nice little buzz going plus a,
you know, I don't know if you'd like
the kids you went to school with.
You want to be able to remember what
the fuck he said. You know, anyways,
underrated.
Having a tight ass for a boss.
As much as everyone wishes that
their boss wasn't such an asshole.
It's about 20 times worse to have
a cool boss that cuts corner,
cuts corners and doesn't do their part.
Yeah.
Then the company goes under and then you
looking for work. Um, overrated. Bill.
Whenever you see a list of
the greatest movies ever made,
you will always see gone with
the wind on that list. Right?
My family and I decided to watch it
for the first time on Thanksgiving.
It was fucking horrible.
It's basically a three hour movie
about a self centered content
throughout the movie.
You watched this bitch gold dig her way
through without any remorse for anyone
else besides the protagonist
being unlikely unlikable.
The plot is fucking stupid. It really
has no point. When the movie ended,
I yelled, that's it. That's
the big fucking ending.
Avoid at all costs.
None of us liked it.
Uh,
I got it. I have to watch it now. Is
that the one we ends? Frankly, my dear,
I don't give a damn. That was basically
the 1940s version of saying, yeah,
why don't you go fuck
yourself? You cunt. All right.
You've got to be old and you too.
You're going to fall. And then
where are you going to be? Huh?
Do you hear teased up on all those goddamn
noodles sitting here on the fucking
plantation? What are you gonna do
then? Not even the non hired help.
I'll listen to you. So go fuck yourself
right there as soon to be flabby. Tits.
Okay? If you're not coming with
love, all you got to, you looks okay.
There's no botox at this point in,
in, in, in history. You're finished.
All right?
So why don't you get over here and suck
this Dick while you still can and then
[inaudible] and they roll the
fucking credits. All right,
Neil. Log preview here.
Everybody. Um, this was sent to me.
Hey, build, love the podcast back.
Cataloguing it like crazy. Thank
you. Here's my fucking problem.
I got a roommate who was wonderful.
We're buddies.
We watched stupid shit. You know
what? Fuck this. I gotta make this.
I gotta make this larger. This
print is too small. Here we go.
I've actually learned how to do this.
Select everything. Uh, go up here.
Go from 12.
Okay,
let's make it fucking 18 like a
grandmother. There we go. All right.
I got a roommate who's wonderful.
We're buddies.
We watch stupid shit and left
together about it. All right. Uh,
he's got this girlfriend who's a drain
on everything that is fun in the world.
I'm not talking the regular guy, girl
argument crap. I mean, everything.
Quick example,
we were watching that BBC planet Earth
series and we just joking at the most
beautiful shit in the world,
literally,
and all she could do is bitch
about how ugly the birds were.
Complained about David Attenborough's
voice or get mad at some animal just
because it's killing another animal
to fucking survive. After we finished,
she said she would love to be on the
crew of a nature documentary shoot.
She's got no soul. The guy loves her.
They'd been together for over a year,
but it's so clear he can't stand to
be around her. They only ever argue,
okay.
Oh, they only argue and not in that great
way that you and Nia did in one of the
podcasts where you all laughed
with each other. It's unbearable.
And she's at my apartment five days a
week. Yeah, dude, you know something.
I get it.
You're in a relationship but either
move in with this bitch or let's have a
fucking two days here,
two days there. You know,
you got eight home games a year,
you got eight away games in the NFL.
Let's try to set it up the same
fucking way. So this is like baseball.
At some point you got to have a fucking
road trip. Okay. There's sport. Um,
anyways,
most nights I eventually either drink
or smoke or just so I'm not in the same
world as her and I like
smoking. Who am I kidding? Uh,
I want to talk to him about it,
but he's a really private guy.
We've never talked about his
relationship stuff. He stands to tea,
tends to steer away from it.
It's becoming pretty obvious
that I can't stand this girl,
nor can any of our friends. I'm afraid
that she's going to drive us apart.
Then feast on his soul. She, she,
she can try and find some kind
of personality for herself.
How do you think I should
approach this with this guy?
I got a right to complain to him about
this girl, right. Got To do a tender,
Leah something. Um, all
right. This is the deal.
I almost started singing
when a man loves a woman,
but I'm not going to do that to you.
Okay.
But it's true. Okay.
When a man loves a woman,
no other way to get into this point.
I can't believe I was able to say
that without singing it. Uh, even,
even I as much as bad as I sing, no,
I can't even, you want me to do it?
All right.
Wow.
Um,
there's no fucking way you can approach,
um, the country things that
annoy you about them. Well,
you have to do is just walk into another
room and just like literally just grab
a pillow off of the couch.
You know,
after she says something and you just
walk in the other room, you just go,
yeah.
And then you just come back in and he go,
oh, so what are you major in? All right.
You just do that.
But you do have a right as a roommate
to have some sort of parameters,
all right? The problem is, is you've
let it get out of control. All right?
So here's the deal. Either this dude's
going to marry this girl or he isn't,
okay. He's going to marry this girl. Your
guys, your friendship is fucking over.
You're not going to hang out with him
cause he's, he's with this colossal cunt.
You're gonna meet somebody else.
Then eventually you're gonna get married.
You can have kids, you barely gonna
have time to see this person anyways,
even if you liked his wife, okay.
But the fact that she's a cunt,
she's just going to fade out anyways,
okay? So there's nothing to worry about.
They're losing this friendship.
If he's going to marry this girl,
it's fucking overdue. Okay.
It's a done deal. All right?
MMM.
And if he's eventually going
to break up with their,
whatever you're going to say to him now,
he's eventually going to come around and
he's going to be saying all this shit
that you're going to say to
him or want to say to him.
So you don't need to say it.
You just get you all.
What you really have to deal with right
now is just trying to cut down the
amount of time that,
that fucking, that, that,
that hell content comes into
your apartment five days a week.
Dude, I don't care if you even
like to just say, listen. Um,
I respect you and your relationship.
You know, I'm really happy for you.
You seem really happy,
but you know,
it's just a gel. This is fucking hard.
She's coming over here five days a week.
Ken,
is there any way you can,
you can kind of cut that in half
a couple of nights over her place.
Because I like to come out here,
like to smoke a fucking bomb and
I like to watch the fucking TV.
What are they do? You could
do though what you do? Ah,
yeah, but she's, I,
I like to do it in a country atmosphere
that has no fucking way to do this.
MMM.
You know what, you just basically
going to have to ask yourself,
what's more important to you,
your friendship with this guy or you're,
you're fucking,
you know,
your ability to fucking have a beer and
smoke a joint without this bitch fucking
ruined and you, you, you know, five nights
a week. Okay, I would suggest this. Okay.
If you still want to be friends with this
guy, he didn't want to rock the boat,
then I would look for another place to
live if you could, which is fucking sucks.
You got to pay to move. But I'm telling
you, you're going to be psyched.
How old are you? Do maybe it's time you
should fucking live alone, you know,
cause you might jump out of this,
out of the fireman and out of the fire
into the what and out of the frying pan
into the fire though.
This is fucking rough.
Okay.
I don't know how to just
say it. So listen, dude,
I don't know how to say this to you
because I feel like however I say it,
you're going to feel like I'm
attacking you and that you know,
you're going to say something to your
girlfriend and she's gonna think that I
don't like her, which I
don't. Um, just say, listen,
she's coming over here five days a
week. She's not paying rent. You know,
I like hanging out watching
TV and I'm coming over here.
She's taken up half the couch.
I just need just can we cut it down to
four days a week, three days a week?
I don't mind her coming over
here. Just not five out of
the seven days. All right.
I want to come out here and my underwear,
rub my balls,
drink a fucking beer and watch the game.
I don't want to come out here, you know,
dress like a, I'm a on fathers
knows best. You know, you know,
back in the day that fathers would walk
around the house and a God damn suit,
right?
You know what, dude? Sometimes
you just got to burn a friendship.
There's all different ways you
can do that. You could just,
you could just be honest and
just say, listen to it. If
this fucking girl comes
over here one more time.
So do you like mommy to cut it
down to like three days a week now?
How about zero?
How would you break up with her and
realize you can get somebody better?
How about that?
You know,
I dunno. So that, that is definitely a
rough one. I gave you a number of options.
Um,
I would in no way say how
you feel about that girl,
the of buddy. You can't do
that. Um, I mean, he can't,
but there's just going to be
ramifications to that. But uh,
I would definitely try to get that, you
know, try to get that number knocked down.
All right.
Did I just say the same thing for
fucking 20 minutes over and over again?
All right. There's an hour.
There's an hour for you. All right.
That's the Monday morning
podcast for this week.
I'm going to be at the
Brayer Comedy Club in, uh,
in Bray California.
Let me get to my fucking website that
evidently that guy's got me feeling bad
about you.
Give a shit about your food.
I hope you do because if you don't,
it's really sad.
Oh, Jesus shows, here we go. I'm
going to be at the Brayer Improv. Uh,
November 30th,
December 1st and December 2nd.
All right. Friday, Saturday,
Sunday of this week.
This is my last headlining
Gig of the year.
If your dream was to see
me at some point in 2012,
this is your last chance.
Um,
I guarantee you're going to see a great
show because I'm loving my act right now.
And um,
I took last weekend off and I'm chomping
at the bit to get on stage and I got a
bunch of new fucked up shit that
I want to talk about and uh,
watch something the other night that I
got really inspired by actually watch the
documentary of the making
of Michael Jackson's bad.
And it just made me feel like I,
I don't work nearly, you know,
I don't work hard enough.
It was really fucking inspiring and
also kill me as I got off at that subway
stop with a,
with a shot the old day,
the whole dance thing
for bad and it's weird.
It's like you come down the stairs and
there's a middle level and then you go
downstairs again and the amount of
times I've ran through there trying to
fucking catch a train and
didn't even look around.
I wonder if I looked around at what a
noticed it I think would have to be like
nobody in there. If it was a bunch of
people I don't think I would've noticed.
But if I was there late at night and I
was looking around making sure I wasn't
going to get jumped,
you know,
I wonder if I would have
noticed.
I probably wouldn't have,
I probably wouldn't even notice if I
was fucking coming down with my iPod
listening to the song bad.
Ill Do, do, do, do, do, do, do,
do bill bill, Bill, Bill, Bill.
I would've walked right by
la. Um, anyways. All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you everybody for listening.
I hope you had a great thanksgiving.
Um, and that is it. Ed.
Um, thanks to the person who organized
the High School Union. Like I said,
I don't name names here.
Uh,
I had a great time and I think I'm
going to go to the next one. All righty.
That's it. Go fuck yourselves. I'll
talk to you next week. Oh, gee. Sheesh.